thank you
[Music]
name the city
where there is a fine dining Cafe
for dogs Tokyo dude La for dogs
isn't it Asia don't don't do that you're
not
yulin
yes no I was like if that's a double
entender like four dogs four dogs it's
not a cannibal the park Silver Lake one
of those special hipster places Portland
you guys can do this really
Florida sand frame guys oh
Jesus
epitome of straight up douchebaggery in
history is that the mecca though all of
the wrong problems people with seven
messenger bags on I feel like Silver
Lake is not even that hipster like that
no they're normies compared to just kind
of our normies compared to that they
have the uh enamel of hipster but
they're not because San Francisco has
turned into a tech City for me like it's
changed from like the hippie hipster to
like
tech people that are really [__] rich
but they pretend that they're only
experiencing a mass Exodus of that right
now yeah because well
big time yeah well because they're
getting fired well because silicon
Valley's downsizing the companies are
disappearing they're just leaving so now
all the prices are up nobody to take
their spots and all the Innovation isn't
there now that they're all going to
Austin is that true
I think they're dispersing there's a lot
of people are just nowhere to go like
New York and Cali are losing people for
sure good
good for the traffic huh yeah hey
traffic by the way has been easy mode
since I've been here which is really
actually it's kind of crazy I like that
yeah I like that okay so
um let's talk about there are dogs
and leather-lined booths
right they there's a San Francisco Cafe
just for dogs and on Sundays it offers a
75 tasting menu
and since its debut in my modified for
tasty 75 for tasting this one's a stupid
[__]
yeah how do you prevent one of your
customer dogs from running across the
table eating the food of another
customer or beefing with the other booth
and they're all fighting and eating each
other and [__] each other's [__]
going on dates and just ruining a bunch
of swingers dude there's a lot of drama
have you seen it dude have you guys been
to a [__] dog park and he's seen like
what kind of [__] goes around over
there there's always one [__] that
like takes their dog off a leash but
their dog is like super aggressive yeah
and it gets in the other dog's face fine
yeah it's like get the [__] out of here
man and somehow he has a service dog
service dog bro some of these dogs don't
deserve their owners at all a golden
doodle with a service dog vest on and
says don't pat me the dog's like [__]
jumping in my lap
this is
an ass though dude you can't ask come
here yeah you can't be like provide the
paperwork oh Chinese people will ask I
try to go into restaurants and like is
that uh and like oh yeah it's a service
give me the paper and I'm like that's
illegal technically illegal yeah it's
illegal he goes I don't care no animal
and I'm like [__] it's illegal but she's
licking her lips can't even ask why you
can isn't it you can say like you can
decline it if it if it prevents your
service or business from being able to
accurately like perform its tasks or
something I don't think anyone is has
more power than the Ada so the minute
they're like oh you want you're not you
don't want to be 88 compliant then
they'll go report your ass because that
used to happen to us and then we were
like well let's check this out and it's
we consulted to the Ada and they said oh
so we didn't allow dogs
um to be you can't you can't rent the
photo studio to take dog photos but you
can have your dog as emotional support
or whatever if you need a service dog
because that's okay yeah but then people
would try to say oh I just need my five
dogs with me and then they just take
photos of the dogs on the sets and we're
like Ada's like no you need to report
that to us and we take their like
but if you ask about like hey why do you
need this dog you can't ask why do you
need this stuff yeah because that's
illegal well are you depressed or
something yeah
you can't it's weird it's like you can
ask but you can't say
hey why do you need this dog and the
answer will determine whether or not you
get the service you can't do that you
can just ask and be like oh what's up
what's wrong with you what if they go
like I put peanut butter I put peanut
butter on my dick and it licks it off oh
yeah you're like please get the [__] out
of my stuff and he's like is that not a
service animal hey
Ada does want to know when people are
abusing it because it does mess it up
for people that really have actual
service dog and there's a difference now
there's emotional support yeah and then
there's the actual service animal PTSD
and most please people uh most places
don't allow the emotional support one
anymore ninety percent of them are
emotional support 90 I swear to God okay
so there was a there was a a chef his
name is Rami maserwa nailed it classic
classical trained Chef started this
Venture after burning out in fine dining
kitchens humans he said could just never
appreciate his art the way that dogs
dogs be appreciating food
humans could never appreciate his life
sucks ass maybe he's like maybe I need
to not season the food that I'll give to
the dog dogs would be happy to eat like
a rotten piece of meat that's been left
for a [__] week covered in ants
they'll be like [__] yeah
and a [__] piece of rock that was
attached to it the recent holiday prefix
menu commenced with an antelope heart
Pate
encased in a Tiffany blue box wow nobody
cares about that which the dog
delicately flicked away with his tongue
oh don't give a [__] about the color of
the box but yo Antelope [__] Pate
you were he's you're killing it today
thank you he's not going off script um
he playing a straight man right now so
usually he's actually reading the
article today that's killing it you
gotta get real information with this
information
I learned from CIS huh okay so he also
he also
um has
this kibble that is garnished with a
drizzle of olive oil some shaved
Parmesan Parmesan or a Sprinkle of
katsubiyoshi what the [__] wait no you
don't nailed it just serving kibble on
top of as a garnish he said here's
kibble and now they put some salt and
pepper it's cable elevated
think about kibble yeah and now elevator
he's like I'm gonna I'm gonna open up
this can of [__] pedigree and then
head downstairs
thank you and then just shave some black
truffle on there 75 well I mean the
second you say black Shuffle on anything
that's what I'm saying worth it but like
you're dealing with a good Super Bass
that can't complain about it yeah
also a beef liver flan what you like
that that's kind of Thai with pumpkin
pearls under an edible honeycomb cage
it's not 75 TY but it's like tight like
I would love to feed that to my cats
right I think that is a cool idea though
can I eat it too and then I we eat like
we split the the meal you have to have a
service animal vest yeah yeah oh you
have to worry you know what's I'm a
service human I think this is gonna be
[__] up because all it's gonna take is
like one dog to get maybe like a
stomachache or just not sit well with
the food because you know some certain
dogs yeah bro like those two happy dogs
because dogs parents are like they don't
[__] around businesses are just like
dude it's always going to do amazing
yeah just sell some bones by the way
they're they're water has cucumber
slices in it wow I don't know if dogs
will like that would they I don't think
they will some dogs don't like ice water
but some dogs love it you know sometimes
I really hate humans dogs like sometimes
drink water with their own poop in it
yeah like you see the dog park it's like
humans are [__] dumb dude dude there
was that why because we've been on
inventions like this yeah like we put
our own stuff we put our they think
you're gems down dog look at your gym is
dumb humans another Chef he thinks your
ideas don't no no I think humans are
dumb because we put our expectations on
animals and animals have their own
expectations
um
humans can edit animal expectations
that's true they perceive it however
they want to pursue I think my dog needs
shoes now all of a sudden all that when
you
fix on animals anthropomorphosis yeah is
it adamors
[Laughter]
to dogs that
nurse yeah dude pretty [__] funny
dude I love anything dogs really me too
but this is too much you know it's a
crazy coincidence uh this one time I was
with Redfoo at Coffee Bean we were in
the Hollywood one he runs into people
all the time that just have long
conversations with him he just continues
the conversation he just loves doing
that but this one day it was these three
guys and they started talking about
business and they were like hey we got
three business ideas we want to run them
by you just get your opinion what you
think sounds good yeah and then they
name like these two uh things I forgot
the third one sounded cool and who was
like he's like yo that's the one like
that's really great like a year later we
run into these guys again at the lobby
of some building we were doing like a TV
show pitch and they were in the lobby
right and they're like yo it's us like
we talked to you we got our business
going everything you know what the
business was it ended up taking that
whole first floor of this building in
Hollywood it was wag
no way with the pet store the pet
everything they do like they walk your
dog now they have pet hotel all that
stuff right these three dudes made one
holy [__] yeah it was the trippiest red
Foods just like [__] pitching it's
just like like a shark tank in it yeah
it was wonderful they weren't asking for
money they were just like hey what's
your opinion I'll give you a royalty
deal I'll give you a royalty it's like
so sick to just like see these guys and
it was like a year later
yeah yeah they went up to him to just
like like talk and stuff and shoot the
[__] and they want to shuffle yeah they
just got into that whole thing and then
and then seeing their that was their
first office it was already gigantic and
they were like yeah we're gonna try to
expand into into SF all this stuff we're
like dude this is gonna totally kill
good for that yeah so this guy this chef
says his his tasting menu is a journey a
journey of flavor is he trolling
all dogs want to do is smell other dogs
asses and eat random Pizza not cold yeah
I think this guy like really loves dogs
and loves animals probably she doesn't
know [__] about dogs but but yeah that's
the other that's the flip this was just
guessing and [__] he's probably just
blowing smoke up his own ass he says
that his dogs which this triggered me
too their names are grizzly and Luna
[__] Grizzly I would hate that I
don't like the name Grizzly that'll be a
terrible crypto coach
um are now his primary taste testers and
he samples all the dishes himself as
well there's no seasoning no aromatics
he samples them himself yeah but the
food isn't made for the human palette he
says yeah it's made for dogs
if they were selling this for like 25
bucks though or 20 bucks oh yeah this is
fresh like I would totally bring my
animals there you know what I mean you
bring your cat sir absolutely and my and
myself I'll probably eat it
[Music]
foreign